the scene of ron loopy on love potion  falling off the couch was not scripted  so the reactions of daniel radcliffe and  jim broadbent were genuine  the golden trio were actually laughing  when discussing harry's kiss with cho as  hermione's quip about ron having the  emotional range of a teaspoon had them  cracking up  tom felton forgot his line in this scene  from the chamber of secrets and instead  genuinely remarked on goyle's reading  abilities what the naked brain lucius  wasn't meant to utter the unforgivable  curse in this scene but he forgot the  original spell he was going to say and  just said the one that came to his mind  in the moment  [Music]